en el último vídeo vimos que el hecho de
que exista una solución para esta
ecuación para alguna escala blanda y
algún vector ve distinto de cero es
equivalente al hecho de que la matriz
lambda por la identidad menos a tenga
determinante igual a cero
o dicho de otro modo lambda es un valor
propio un valor propio de la matriz a si
y sólo si sí y sólo sí
el determinante de lambda por la
identidad menos a es igual a cero en
este vídeo vamos a aprender cómo podemos
utilizar esta información para obtener
un valor concreto un valor específico
para el valor propio lambda vamos a
hacer un ejemplo de una matriz de 2 x 2
digamos que la matriz a es igual a la
matriz 1 243 muy bien y quiero encontrar
los valores propios de a así que sí
lambda es un valor propio de la matriz a
un valor propio de la matriz a entonces
es necesario que lambda satisfaga que el
determinante de la matriz lambda por la
identidad en este caso de 2 por 2 100 1
lambda por la identidad menos la matriz
a en este caso es la 1 243 esto debe ser
igual a 0
y esto aquí es igual pues esto es lo
mismo que el determinante de lambda por
la identidad es blanda por 1 holanda por
una es lambda blanda por 0 0 blando por
0 0 irlanda por 1 es lambda y ahora le
restó la matriz a es decir le restó la
matriz 1 243 y esto debe de ser igual a
0 ahora bien esta diferencia de matrices
se reduce a el determinante de la matriz
lambda menos 1 donde menos 10 menos 2
que es menos 2
20 - 4 que sería menos 4 y luego lambda
menos 3 lambda menos 3 esta matriz
simplemente es el resultado de hacer
toda la simplificación la simplificación
de la matriz lambda por la identidad
menos la matriz a recuerden que la
matriz identidad la tengo que tomar de
la misma dimensión que la matriz a así
que esto es simplemente esta expresión y
cuál es el determinante de esta matriz
pues es el producto de estos 2 - el
producto de los otros dos así que es
lambda menos uno por lambda menos 3
1 - 3 - el producto de menos 4 x menos 2
menos 4 x menos dos es 8 positivo así
que menos 8 y esto es el determinante de
la matriz lambda por la identidad plaza
se simplifica y se reduce a esta matriz
esto debe ser cero para que lambda sea
un valor propio así que tengo esta
ecuación en lambda y sus soluciones son
precisamente los valores propios valores
propios lambda que hacen que el espacio
nulo de la matriz lambda por la
identidad menos a sea no trivial bien
pues ahora sólo tengo que encontrar las
raíces de este polinomio en landa si lo
expandimos obtengo lambda al cuadrado
menos 3 lambda menos 3 lambda menos
lambda + 3 menos 8 y eso debe ser igual
a 0 o lo que es lo mismo
lambda cuadrado menos al cuadrado menos
4 lambda + 3 menos 8 sean menos 5 menos
5 y todo eso debe ser igual a 0 muy bien
ahora sólo resta encontrar las raíces de
este polinomio cuadrática vale la pena
mencionar que la expresión que está del
lado izquierdo de esta igualdad se
conoce como el polinomio característico
de la
3a
el polinomio característico de
y si quiero encontrar los valores
propios de a simplemente tengo que
encontrar las raíces de este polinomio
para encontrar los factores lineales de
este polinomio necesito encontrar dos
números cuyo producto sea menos 5 y cuya
suma sea menos 4 esos dos números deben
ser menos 5 y 1 así que los factores
lineales de mi polinomio son lambda
menos 5 y lambda + 1 las raíces del
polinomio característico van a ser
precisamente los valores de lambda que
anulen estos factores así que las raíces
de mi polinomio mis valores propias son
lan de igual a 5 holanda igual a menos 1
ok y con esto ya encontramos los valores
propios que le corresponden a nuestra
matriz a muy bien así que los valores
propios de a son precisamente lambda
igual a 5 y lambda igual a menos 1
ahora esto solo es parte del problema
porque estamos buscando tanto valores
propios como vectores propios nosotros
sabemos que esta ecuación se puede
satisfacer con lambda igual a 5 o menos
1 así que ya sabemos los valores propios
pero nos falta encontrar los vectores
propios y así veremos en el próximo
vídeo